according to the pictograph below how
many survey respondents have type o
positive blood how many have o negative
blood so pictograph is really just a way
of representing data with pictures that
are somehow related to the data so in
this case they give us little pictures
of i'm assuming blood drops right over
here and then they tell us that each
blood drop each blood drop in this
pictograph represents eight people so
you can kind of view that as a scale of
these graphs each of these say eight
people so for example if you say how
many people have a positive it would be
one two three four five six seven blood
drops but each of those blood drops
represent eight people so it would be 56
people have type a positive but let's
answer the actual question that they're
asking us how many survey respondents
have type o positive o positive so this
is o
and then we care about o
positive so we have one blood drop two
three let me do this in a new different
color we have one two three four five
six seven eight
so we have eight drops
i'll put those in quotes because
pictures of drops and then the scale is
the scale is eight people
eight people let me write it this way
times eight people per drop
eight people per drop
and so 8 times 8 and actually even the
drops you can view them as canceling out
if you view them as units so drops drops
8 times 8 is equal to 64
64 people so they could have written
literally the number 64 right over here
64 people have type o
positive blood now let's think about the
o negative case o negative blood well
this is o
and then within the blood group o this
is o negative and we have one drops two
drops so we have two
drops
two drops times eight people per drop
eight people per drop
and so two times eight each of these
represent eight so eight and then 16 or
2 times 8 is equal to 16
16 people so 16 of the survey
respondents 16 have type o negative 64
have type o positive